anyways speaking of Grammys your
soundtrack this is one of my favorite
soundtracks ever waiting to excel
[Applause]
so how did you get you get up in that
film
got a call from Forest Whitaker just
like you do so yeah I was surprised then
of course called me and I I couldn't
believe that he was calling me and he
asked me to be a part of it and asked me
if I would do the music for it and also
score it and I I never scored anything
before and I said I don't know if I can
do that but he said I'm pretty sure you
can you should do it and then I found
out years later that it was actually the
suggestion of Quincy Jones
actually gone to Quincy first so yeah
and then Quincy said no I'm not the one
that should do it you should call
Babyface he's the one that should do
this oh my gosh it was amazing I would
just love that my name was in Quincy
Jones mouth at some point you know like
he just knew my name I was like cool
yeah oh my gosh so Whitney Whitney
picked the artist though right for the
for the album because it's a the
collection of women on this is
incredible yeah yeah
she didn't actually pick the artist we
picked them together she kind of she
would say she said okay but I get to say
who who can and who can't yeah so they
would love it and she was like nah
at some point before I die please tell
me who that is before you die okay okay
I just love that she was like nah pass
hard pass um well one of the women that
Whitney wanted on the album was the
incredible Mary J Blige who I love
I love this song so much this is called
not gonna cry tell us about this one not
gonna cry it was like you know it's
perfect scene in that movie is when um
Bernadette like burns up the house burns
yeah and everything and so like and I
was just there one of the greatest
scenes ever in a movie yeah and so and
when she was tearing up the closet and
everything so it was I had to come with
something that was like heartfelt and
and I thought Mary was the perfect
person to do this and pain heartache she
knew pain yeah well it ended up becoming
her first
top 10 pop record so I did not know what
this song meant when I was like in
junior high but you would have thought I
had felt like like I was like my mom
came in like what is wrong with you like
and I was just like this song I was like
now I get it as an adult grown woman
who's been through
but um yeah hey but anyway
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you